hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 6 video it
was an awesome Bullock slash Edward
nygma episode like really awesome
Riddler Bullock add to that it was also
a super creepy Oswalt episode he is
definitely mommy's special boy generally
I thought this was one of the strongest
episodes so far Donal Logue is an
amazing actor so anytime the show is
gonna focus on his character on the
bullet character I feel like it's gonna
be at its a game so careful for spoilers
if you're not caught up on the episode
but starting with top five moments
number five bullets backstory it's all
deja vu and acid flashbacks to the time
when Bullock was just like Gordon trying
to be the white knight I did like the
way that they played that line you know
a white knight for a different Gotham
then the future Harvey Dent would be the
line was ripped right out of Dark Knight
Harvey Dent went in a slightly different
direction from bullet Bullock is a bit
of a sleazebag but he is no two-face so
being a white knight in Gotham isn't all
it's cracked up to be but I was just
really happy they took the time to
explain Bullock to kind of develop that
character and explain why he's so
cynical
his whole experience with the case also
informs the way he feels about Batman
another pointy-eared vigilante it's
always hard to tell whether taking his
character in modern-day if you've read
the comics you know he's essentially a
police officer like he's not gonna
become some crazy superhero poor super
villain for that matter he's just like
the bellwether for gritty cops and
Gotham like he's always been that one
thing that was a little confusing was
the fact that he would rather go down
for murder than be branded a liar by the
mob it's funny how angry he got at
Gordon whenever they saw Cobblepot at
the end number four
The Riddler in love I just love the
attention to style in that little
records room of Kris kringles or Kristen
kringles you get the sense that nygma is
just gonna get tired of getting kicked
in the pants all the time like Bullitt
kicks him in the pants even though he
appreciates him without saying anything
about it
he's crazy good at puzzles I didn't get
the sense that Kringle was trying to be
cruel to him in the end it was just
really really awkward it was just meant
to be funny I am sure there's already a
ship developing on tumblr right now
between the two of them if any of you
watch community it's like Abed and the
coat-check girl they're perfect for each
other based on the pacing in the last
couple of episodes I think it's gonna be
a long time before nygma does anything
outright evil it'll be a slow chipping
away at his pride until he lashes out
the question mark on the
definitely one of my favorite Easter
eggs number three Selina Kyle and Bruce
Wayne so we finally got the Batman
Catwoman scene that I've been waiting
for it wasn't quite what I expected I
mean it was a sleeping Bruce Wayne still
we're halfway there
I couldn't tell quite what she stole
from him it looked like a cigar case or
just something that belonged to his
father now that she's broken in once I'm
interested to see if she comes back a
second time or if Bruce realizes what
she took and then goes after her I don't
think that he knows about her so I'm
guessing that the first time they
actually do meet face to face it'll be
when she breaks in again she did take
notice of the evidence board so I do
think that they're gonna try to work
together at some point I would be really
happy if they started solving crimes
together Catwoman a little bit of a
burglar so they probably solve crimes
and she'd steal from him at the same
time I don't know about you guys but I
feel like that's a fair trade for some
Catwoman Batman scenes you know if Bruce
just has to give up some of his
valuables every once in a while I do
like the way that Cameron beaconed OVA
acts just a little bit like a cat
creeping around the room cocking her
head to the side number two more awkward
run-ins Cobblepot and his mother
creepiest team ever it's really hard to
get a sense for both of them are coming
from I don't sense any codependence from
Cobblepot
it seems more like his mother is the one
that has trouble letting go the actors
playing her Carol Kane is just perfect
for that role like she's known for
playing characters like that just really
nutty people I definitely got a little
uncomfortable during the bathroom scene
that was major WTF no-fly zone most of
the comics that I've read about the
penguin haven't really dealt with his
inter familiar relationship I just
started reading Gotham Academy that
comic just started and they do talk a
little bit about the rise of the
cobblepot's
as opposed to the rise of the Wayne's it
goes into a little bit about how the
cobblepot's earned their money
historically obviously where we're
seeing them right now in modern day it
seems more like Grey Gardens if you've
seen that documentary it's not a
documentary second docudrama
it is the creepiest thing ever but
basically the cobblepot's earn their
money in a really awful way and the
Wayne's earned it through normal
business so when you're seeing
cobblepot's mother and this really
run-down apartment with these really
shabby looking things that look like
they used to be beautiful it's the last
vestiges of what used to be a really
vast fortune I don't know necessarily
that it's gonna work into cobblepot's
motivation on the show for seeking power
but it's just a big point of interest
for the character something that they
wouldn't normally mention out loud
I always liked learning about characters
families in their backstories especially
when they come from really big families
like the cobblepot's or the Wayans
speaking of which my number one moment
the spirit of the goat lives on did
anyone else get flashes of Court of the
owls I kind of thought that's what they
might be doing in this episode with the
goat character like it was a group of
people controlling the goats instead of
just the psychiatrist or the hypnotist
or however you want to think about it if
you haven't read court of the owls it's
probably one of the best Batman titles
ever I don't want to spoil it but it's a
very Wayne family centric story and all
say is that the only natural predator
that the bat has is the owl so just
think about that court of owls owls a
bats predator it's a very awesome story
definitely check it out based on the
explanation they gave us I don't think
that we're gonna be seeing the goat
anytime soon like she's gonna get locked
up probably go to Arkham eventually
might end up working there apparently
they hire psychos I definitely got some
Arkham flashbacks
especially when cobblepot's mother
mentioned The Painted Lady just a nice
Easter egg for Harley Quinn also an
alumni of Arkham Asylum I did chuckle
just a little bit whenever milky put the
mask on and called himself the goat and
spoke in Batman voice I thought he might
be zas for a minute just because their
voices sounded a little bit similar
especially whenever we was doing the
Batman voice but that's a completely
separate character he's coming in
another episode there really is like
this divide between what people think
the city needs and what is appropriate
everyone is going too far
Batman is like the middle ground but he
is like 10 years away
that's an interesting to think about
like they flash back 10 years into the
past that were in present day Batman is
supposedly 10 years in the future let me
know that what was your favorite moment
from the episode and what do you think
is gonna happen with the Montoya plot
that was actually a pretty big WTF for
me too like I have no idea where they're
taking that storyline right now it kind
of feels like she's the most unlikable
character on the show I mean she's
trying to do her job I don't think that
her dislike of Gordon is unreasonable
but she took on the entire Police
Department like she's putting her
reputation on the line because of this
Cobblepot murder and then he just blows
right in the door
they're actually gonna be consequences
for a lot of people because of this so
one Montoya is gonna be a bit of a
douchebag to Gordon and Bullock are not
gonna have to deal with Falcone because
Falcone was the one that ordered them to
kill Cobblepot so the minute people find
out Cobblepot still alive both of them
are going to
on his list or all three of them
that is like he probably still wants
Cobblepot dead it really does seem like
Cobblepot trusts Gordon to like he's not
lying when he told his mother I think I
found someone I could trust I think he
really believes that overall I gave the
episode a solid b-plus you can't go
wrong with Donal oak and I just love
that nygma got some love that whole
scene in the clerks file room that was
like the longest scene he's ever had
they did tell us at the beginning of the
season that all the characters would
kind of get their own episodes maybe not
own episodes but at least much bigger
storylines as the season got on like
there's a lot of characters it's gonna
take time to get to each of them I do
kind of hope nygma gets a second chance
with Kringle although it looks like it's
gonna be a while looks like she's gonna
have to cool off a little bit
thanks to Donal loads performance I do
feel a lot more sympathetic for the
Bullock character if you've only seen
the animated series like the classic
Batman the Animated Series but luck just
seems like a butthole like he clearly
hates Batman this person who's trying to
do good things inside the city now
though we kind of understand why that is
he's just predisposed to not like him
just because of his experience with
people wearing masks I like the way that
they're teasing vigilantes on the show
like as we're getting on through the
episodes you get the feeling that the
police department as well as Bullock and
the main characters are just getting
totally fried on vigilantes so that by
the time Batman comes around they're
definitely gonna be gunning for him but
here are just a couple other really
funny things in the episode that I've
picked out just some of my favorite
moments first off Bullock is paying his
partner dicks hospital bills
and sending him porn care packages
totally awesome partner then I actually
had like an Arrested Development
hallucination when Bullock went ther
rapist I just thought of an al rapist it
would be so amazing to give some of the
other characters some atoh biases lines
to be real though I hope they don't do
that that would be totally inappropriate
as funny as Gotham tries to be sometimes
and that's totally intentional like it's
meant to be funny
I know sometimes there can be confusion
because the Dark Knight trilogy took
itself so seriously and this show is a
little bit more like the classic TV
series in the Michael Keaton movies at
least from a visual perspective a lot of
you have also asked me when this falls
in the timeline I would pin it around
the Michael Keaton Batman films just
based on the way that things look I know
the cityscapes can be a little deceiving
because they look a little bit more
modern but you really need to look
inside the buildings and when you look
at the cars to like you don't see
Lamborghinis
around like you don't see a lot of
modern cars speaking of sets though I
have to say the Playhouse probably one
of my favorite Gotham sets so far even
though I'll give them a flag on the play
for excessive use of Dutch angles if
you're not sure what a Dutch angle is
that's just where they twist the camera
like this on all totally great episode
for Halloween this kind of was like
their Halloween week episode but lots
other big stuff happening so tomorrow
Marvel is making a huge announcement or
this morning it's actually like past 12
a.m. now as I'm making this video so
definitely check that out I'll be
posting a new video based on what they
announce more New Avengers age of Ultron
footage tonight - or like a second
trailer I also just got a copy of world
of Ice and Fire so if you guys are Game
of Thrones fans I'll be posting videos
based on that - throughout the week so
in case you haven't seen it yet
Benedict Cumberbatch Doctor Strange
internet blew up this morning you can
click here to learn all about that and
you can click here for last week's
Gotham thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five I'll see you guys
later today
you